one theme that has come up over and over
throughout candyman's sorted history is
the comparison of how people see him as
an urban legend and how devotees
interact with religion from his clothing
to his sermon likee monologues to the
many other references and religious
subtexts that I pointed out in this
video I think the lack of definitive
evidence provided to make people believe
in him operates the same way as religion
religion is all about faith followers of
a religion may have a relationship with
God but it's never in the form of
irrefutable proof that God exists
because that wouldn't be faith that
would just be like proofed but the main
point that I'm getting at here is that
those who believe do so even without
proof and the point behind Candyman is
that urban legends and Supernatural
hook-handed Killers operate very much
the same way the mystery around the
whole thing creates Believers whether it
be Candyman Bloody Mary the hookman or
any other urban legend and this is what
gives power to those Legends